nobody has the balls to come out and say
it and just say look 85% of you have to
go that's it my boy and one of my wife
was pregnant I say my wife you know
she's pregnant and then I always have
these people they excuse me you're
supposed to say we're pregnant it's best
to say we're pregnant
it's like well I'm not a seahorse so
tell you we need a plate don't be afraid
it's only good it's only gonna kill the
weak like there is no reason to hit a
woman there is no reason to hit a woman
and I was just like really I could give
you like 17 right at the top of my head
you can wake me from a drunken stupor I
could still give you like 9 you're women
not just constantly patting themselves
on the back about how difficult their
lives are and no one corrects them
because they want to [ __ ] them
this girl gives me [ __ ] she goes so why
does a guy make more an hour to do the
exact same job I go I'll tell you why
because in the unlikely event that we're
both on a Titanic and it starts to sink
for some fucked-up reason you get to
leave with the kids
he goes what are your goals in the robot
goes out to become smarter than human
beings yeah
and the reporter just blows biting it's
like okay Anna what's your favorite
color
anytime you do anything remotely
sensitive heartwarming anything that's
going to make you more of a loving
caring individual immediately all your
guy friends suggest that maybe just
maybe you want to suck a dick so there
is an epidemic of gold-digging [ __ ] in
this country is this critical point when
you stay single too long and when your
brain switches from you know like don't
say that - yeah [ __ ] say it
see what happens now have you have the
male feminist like where the [ __ ] did
that come from just out of nowhere last
couple years I'm a male feminist
I've always championed women tell you
happens why would you listen to another
human being tell you where you're gonna
go when you die it's just like dude have
you ever been dead no great so would it
be safe to assume that you wouldn't have
the slightest [ __ ] idea what you're
talking about
just some guy you name's Jerry you
played soccer you got your ass kicked in
gym class and now you're doing this I
don't want you guys I didn't come from a
touchy-feely call me when you get here
and none of that [ __ ] first time I mom
hugged me which i think was like once
when I was little and then when I moved
out that was it
what does I send me saw a kid riding a
bicycle down the street dude you're
never gonna see that [ __ ] again you
never see him playing outside him two
parents just have him inside now man
then just feeding them and feeding them
you know he's making him fatter and
fatter trying to make him unfuckable you
ever try to get fat now you don't have
to it's effortless my dad's the greatest
dude I ever met my life and he had a
temper any time anything broke in the
house five minutes into fixing it he was
bitching about his marriage was
hilarious
he'd see some broth oh Christ will you
look at ya that's why there's no traffic
on the Serengeti bunch of lions just
standing there in gridlock the [ __ ] is
going on
look look no means no no that means no
all right but no stop it what are you
doing
so bad I can't even watch the NBA
anymore man it's like every high like
the white dudes like that the flank use
nothing his nuts in his face
something has to die everyday in order
for me to live something's got to get
his beak chopped off feathers yanked up
a cut to its jaw anytime you hear a guy
say I'm a male feminist I always just
think that is the most pathetic
limp-dick way ever to try and get some
[ __ ] right I want to feel your power
but I want to be safe but let me know if
you really want it to you know that that
whole Fifty Shades of rape whatever the
hell it is that's how angry my brain is
it can't be just like you know what hey
let's get a pumpkin scope you don't [ __ ]
this let's get a pump finally ask the
one Dells like how come we never did the
hugging thing you know what I mean how
come we didn't do that stuff she's like
well I wanted to hug you kids when you
were little but I was afraid it was
gonna make you gay either I'm gonna get
married you know I'm just getting up
being that creepy old guys hanging out
at a bar you know red chest hair hanging
out
what are you affair look if you if you
beat a dick apologize but other than
that yeah go [ __ ] yourself you're gonna
build a wall from [ __ ] California to
Texas you're gonna do this I'll tell you
by the time they finished it this
country would be so [ __ ] up we're
gonna be the ones going over it